do you think
china and us
are going to um escalate
something that would be called the war
purely in the space of cyber
i believe
any
geopolitical conflict
from now on
is guaranteed to have some cyber element
to it
the department of justice recently
declassified a report that said china's
been hacking into our pipelines and it's
not for intellectual property theft it's
to get a foothold
so that if things escalate in taiwan for
example
they are where they need to be to shut
our pipelines down and we just got a
little glimpse of what that looked like
with colonial pipeline
and the panic buying and the jet fuel
shortages and that assessment i just
mentioned about the diesel
so
they're there you know they've got in
there
um any time i read a report about new
aggression from fighter jets chinese
fighter jets in taiwan
or what's happening right now with
russia's build up on the ukraine border
or india pakistan i'm always looking at
it through a cyber lens and it really
bothers me that other people aren't
because there is no way
that these governments and these nation
states are not going to use their access
to gain some advantage
uh in those conflicts
and you know i'm now in a position where
i'm
an advisor to the cyber security uh
infrastructure security agency at the
dhs so
i'm not saying anything classified here
but i just think that
it's really important to understand just
generally what the collateral damage
could be for american businesses and
critical infrastructure in any of these
escalated conflicts around the world
because just generally
our adversaries have learned
that
they might never be able to match us in
terms of our traditional military
spending on traditional weapons and
fighter jets
but we have a very soft underbelly when
it comes to cyber
or more of america's critical
infrastructure so
pipelines power grid nuclear plants
water systems
is owned and operated by the private
sector
and for the most part there is nothing
out there
legislating that those companies
share the fact they've been breached
they don't even have to tell the
government they've been hit
there's nothing mandating that they even
meet a bare minimum standard of cyber
security
um and that's it
so
even when there are these attacks most
the time we don't even know about it
so that is you know if you were going to
design a system to be as
blind and vulnerable as possible that's
a that is pretty pretty good
that's what it looks like is what we
have here in the united states
and
everyone here is just operating like
let's just keep hooking up everything
for convenience you know software eats
the world
let's just keep going for cost for
convenience sake just because we can
and when you study these issues and you
study these attacks and you study
the advancement and the
uptick in frequency and the
the lower barrier to entry that we see
every single year
you realize just how dumb
software eats world is
and no one has ever stopped to pause and
think
should we be hooking up these systems to
the internet
they've just been saying can we let's do
it
and that's a real problem and this and
just in the last year you know we've
seen a record number of zero-day attacks
i think there were 80 last year
which is probably more than double what
it was in 2019
[Music]
a lot of those were nation states
uh you know we live in a world with a
lot of geopolitical hot points right now
and
where those geopolitical hot points are
are places where
countries have been investing heavily in
offensive cyber tools
if you're a nation state
the goal would be to maximize the
footprint of zero day like super secret
zero day that nobody's aware of
and whenever
war is initiated the huge negative
effects of shutting down infrastructure
or any kind of zero day is the chaos it
creates
so if you just there's a certain
threshold when you create the chaos
the the markets plummet just everything
goes
goes to hell
so it's not just zero days you know we
make it so easy
for for threat actors i mean
we're not using two-factor
authentication we're not patching
um there was the shell shock
vulnerability that was discovered
a couple years ago it's still being
exploited no because so many people
haven't fixed it
um
so you know the zero days are really the
sexy stuff and what really got drew me
to the zero day market was the moral
calculus we talked about
um
particularly from you know the us
government's point of view how do they
justify
leaving these systems so vulnerable
when we use them here and we're baking
more of our critical infrastructure with
this vulnerable software you know it's
not like we're using one set of
technology and russia's using another
and china's using this we're all using
the same technology
so when you find a zero day in windows
you know you're not just leaving it open
so you can spy on russia or implant
yourself in the russian grid you're
leaving americans vulnerable too
but
you know but zero days are like that is
the secret sauce you know that's the
that's the superpower you know and i and
i always say like every country now with
the exception of antarctica someone
added the vatican to my list
is trying to find
uh offensive hacking tools and zero days
to make them work and
those that don't have the skills now
have this market that they can tap into
where you know 2.5 million dollars
that's chump change for a lot of these
nation states it's a hell of a lot less
than trying to build the next fighter
jet
um but yeah the goal is chaos i mean why
did russia turn off the lights twice in
ukraine
you know i think
part of it is chaos i think part of it
is to to sow the seeds of doubt in their
current government
your government can't even keep your
lights on why are you sticking with them
you know come over here and we'll keep
your lights on at least you know there's
like a little bit of that
nuclear weapons
seems to have helped prevent nuclear war
is it possible that we have so many
vulnerabilities and so many attack
vectors on each other
that it will
kind of uh achieve the same kind of
equilibrium like mutually shared
destruction
yeah
that's one hopeful solution to this do
you have any hope for this particular
solution
you know nuclear analogies always tend
to fall apart when it comes to cyber
mainly because
you don't need fissile material you know
you just need a laptop and the skills
and you're in the game so it's a really
low barrier to entry
um the other thing is attribution's
harder and we've seen countries muck
around with attribution
we've seen you know nation states
piggyback on other countries spy
operations and just sit there and siphon
out whatever they're getting
we learned some of that from the snowden
documents we've seen russia hack into
iran's command and control attack
servers
we've seen them hit
a saudi petrochemical plant where they
did neutralize the safety locks at the
plan and everyone assumed that it was
iran given iran had been targeting saudi
oil companies forever but nope it turned
out that it was a graduate research
institute outside moscow so
you see countries kind of playing around
with attribution why
i think because they think okay if i do
this like how am i going to cover up
that it came from me because i don't
want to
risk the response
so people are sort of dancing around
this it's just in a very different way
and
you know at the times it covered the
chinese hacks of
infrastructure companies like pipelines
i'd covered the russian probes of
nuclear plants i'd covered covered the
russian attacks on on the ukraine grid
and then in 2018
my colleague david sanger and i covered
the fact that u.s cyber command had been
hacking into the russian grid and making
a pretty loud show of it
and when we went to the national
security council because that's what
journalists do before they publish a
story they give the other side a chance
to respond
i assumed we would be in for that really
awkward painful conversation
where they would say you will have blood
on your hands if you publish this story
and instead they gave us the opposite
answer they said we have no problem
with you publishing this story
why well they didn't say it out loud but
it was pretty obvious they wanted russia
to know that we're hacking into their
power grid too and they better think
twice before they do to us what they've
done to ukraine so yeah you know we have
stumbled
into this new era of mutually assured
digital destruction
um i think another sort of
quasi norm we've we've stumbled into is
proportional responses you know there's
this idea that
if you get hit you're allowed to respond
proportionally
at a time and place of your choosing you
know that is how the language always
goes that's what obama
said after north korea hit sony we will
respond at a time and place of our
choosing
but no one really knows
like what that response looks like and
so what you see a lot of the time are
just these like
just short of war
attacks
you know russia turned off the power in
ukraine but it wasn't like it stayed off
for a week you know it stayed off for a
number of hours
um you know not petcha
hit those companies pretty hard
um but no one died you know and the
question is what's going to happen when
someone dies
and
can a nation state masquerade as a cyber
criminal group as a ransomware group
and that's what really complicates
coming to some sort of digital geneva
convention
like there's been there's been a push
from brad smith at microsoft we need a
digital geneva convention
and on its face it sounds like a
no-brainer yeah why wouldn't we all
agree to stop hacking into each other's
civilian hospital systems elections
power grid
uh pipelines
but when you talk to
people in the west officials in the west
they'll say we would never
we'd love to agree to it but we'd never
do it when you're dealing with she or
putin or kim jong-un
because a lot of times
they outsource these operations to cyber
criminals
in china we see a lot of these attacks
come from this loose satellite network
of private citizens that work at the
behest of the ministry of state security
so how do you come to some sort of state
to state agreement
when you're dealing with
transnational actors and cyber criminals
where it's really hard to pin down
whether that person was acting alone or
whether they were acting at the behest
of the mss or the fsb
and you know a couple years ago i
remember
i can't remember if it was before or
after not pecha but putin said
hackers are like artists who wake up in
the morning in a good mood and start
painting in other words i have no say
over what they do or don't do so how do
you how do you come to some kind of norm
when that's that's how he's talking
about these issues and he's just
decimated merck and you know pfizer and
another you know
however many thousand companies that is
the fundamental difference between
nuclear weapons and cyber attacks
you